we're still in Mexico yes he's here with
me
I'm a terrible pretending to lend and
knowing that my dad is on for you're
gonna be I'm very excited
I don't know we landing here at night
my dad will X is my dad you've never met
parents of another
and tell the people that
today we're going to go to a little town
called akela we might get just daddy's
here we're gonna go see oh we're gonna
see him
Oh
to find my way I'd like to you
cool
get down
now we're going to take a tour of this
Panda and called VESA as a Buddha that's
the name of this being that it would
have been it pretty much it's like its
own little town so it's kind of like a
plantation slash towns here and this has
been though they make tequila and so
we're gonna be learning how to make
Aquila apparently there's other people
are granting the tour to is they're
going to do a Spanish one so they want
us all to be together and so I'm gonna
have to be in charge of translating for
you guys so that's gonna be a challenge
there's no challenge oh I don't know and
my brain is like a throttle in Canada to
eat you add some can't though - okay I
can't do that okay I'm gonna drink some
tequila water water water water right
there get it
listen to heal and hello is that okay
jazz playing ashes water TIF so
responsible has a daughter-in-law you
could take the extra step to translate
everything or you could just focus more
on the fat debris and drink tequila and
have a good time where to get drunk
Bubba no I don't get drunk you don't get
drunk are you excited to start drinking
hey hey big deal at I really hate it I
had your Mexican a horrible experience
when I was way too young to drink and it
was with tequila and for a few years
even just thinking a tequila I would
start like gagging like that's how bad
of an experience I had so I don't know
if I'm going to be drinking any I'll
probably just sip it
however by the harvesting area for the
ghave with tequila and it smells really
good and expect the Roma to be that like
you don't smell like tequila
oh sweet we are supposed to swallow
fiber has a curious to it his guard
as was a
emotional
my dad swears she's getting drunk
already there's no
in his body instrumental my future
father-in-law
yeah no rate of other already bothers
your dad's a rebel on taking through
your mom to your dad was like no I don't
do that if you're like is it illegal
here and I'm like no they don't care
guess it's safe to say that this
marriage will work our our families are
so funny
Isaac yeah I know why not okay
retirement if you aren't tired what
you'll be having about yeah the little H
bar is 1808 Tina I guess I don't like to
see you about the drink
be strong stuff you love it alive well
what you are having a seal when it would
fit in your mouth for five seconds
drink it open exhale that's a cool
dragon breath oh yeah that is pretty
pure like it was I really don't like
tequila I never like face Whitley hey
not so bad here not so bad
there's another thing me
whoo I'm hella heyget Lee after oh you
can do it
why no I've been drinking I've been
drinking this whatever you that's a
gorgeous that the key that was awesome
I don't have a been a change or not but
that was quite an experience but I have
to say the aftertaste in this pub 10
minutes after now I taste like banana
I taste banana in my mouth banana I
faced pineapple yeah he's good African
this sweet is really sweet
really good
what's good fella's Larry and not to
light alcohol you like that I don't like
yes
you got a good exactly because she
wanted
and then you got a good son-in-law I
don't mind drinking how does it feel to
see both our dad yeah cool it's really
good
and it have a very solid person the only
thing I could do this is like the most I
see my dad the hookers
every time I feel malignant he's always
constantly working he only see him like
for a meal and that's it like so to be
able to spend time with him with your
family too is really nice
beautiful
we are in the town of tequila where
tequila was invented there's a law that
says nowhere else in the entire planet
are they allowed to row and make tequila
other than in this state of Jalisco
there's over 1500 different brands of
tequila they all come from here you
can't do thicky lat
ice water water bottle holder which
bottle do we take located aside from my
family come in to vacation and be with
me into there looking for inspiration
for the restaurant cafe Sauceda and I
feel like they're getting very very
inspired now there now there's seriously
thing about remanding to be a full-on
Mexican restaurant
Alyssa Caen you blogging is that your
dad walking no the cameras truck lesson
I wasn't I mean and we think that Isaac
might be coming down with something
he's been very little energy all day we
thought it was just him being quiet just
as all the other days he's been very
vocal about not wanting to do stuff for
running around doing other stuff but now
we're realizing that he actually might
be sick he's accurate temperatures he
was a little warm and he hasn't been
staying a whole lot it either so how you
feeling Isaac yeah he has a fever
the QT the shot
what sorry sauce because what I know
about how Tico's is the soda
I know that with the G lat and then
they'll mix it will go there's a whole
bunch of different drinks so the reason
why we came here those because my uncle
comes here often and he also wants to
show your parents how they make the
drinks here so then they can take that
recipe to get back to Kappa saw Sara and
make mastering anybody Thursday this is
my hand look at that pilot drink nothing
coming three seven liters 72 Street have
a drink Mexican style oh my god I even
did it up wow you're strong
yeah brah hot dogs Roja
Mexican bar food yeah how's Isaac going
because he feels better but in the car
the AC was blasting on him so
I could feel the temperatures
I got pretty buzzed adjust that one dude
I'm trying to keep over your dad hard
for measles he's really hardcore I got I
think I had for a happy having those hmm
I'm good hey it's good drunk oh I drank
a lot of alcohol I don't drink that much
ever I'm a drinkers I just like to drink
on the other vacations and we have in
the vlog trigger pick a schism on
society that looks really pretty
gorgeous girl in the gorgeous field of
the gorgeous sunlight with some gorgeous
drinks like a model
all right finish drinking or hot ethos
get the cups
near where I used to live with my sister
where I was studying too
we're ready an accountant
good very good
will you just do something like that
this is authentic mexican sri taco I
don't know what's wrong with American
they make everything worse this is
awesome open open it